merci bonsoir moi je m'appelle sophie et
depuis tout petit j'avais qu'une envie
c'était celle de voyager et de me barrer
et aujourd'hui si je travaille pour un
site de voyage s'est pas seulement pour
aider n'importe qui a avant les
informations qu'ils recherchent sur le
voyage mais c'est aussi parce que je
pense sincèrement que le voyage est un
facteur non innocents pour aider à faire
changer et à évoluer les mentalités
depuis la nuit des temps l'homme est
parti à la conquête à la recherche de
nouvelles terres et de nouvelles idées
si malheureusement ces rencontres au
début ce sont quand même super mal passé
et qu'elles ont beaucoup donné lieu à la
domination d'un peuple par un autre la
colonisation
aujourd'hui ça se passe quand même assez
bien et le voyage est synonyme de
plaisir et de découverte
le voyage est aussi devenue une
philosophie il y a des gens qui voyagent
en permanence par envie par désir ce que
je vais vous montrer ici aujourd'hui ce
que j'aimerais vous faire passer comme
message c'est qu'en voyageant vous
pouvez avoir bien plus d'impact que vous
ne le pensez si on regarde un peu en
france il ya de plus en plus de gens qui
voyagent la première raison comment on
peut le voir facilement c'est facebook
vos amis ils pourrissent votre mur avec
des photos de vacances pendant que vous
vous travaillez ensuite si on regarde
les noms plus concrètement même si pas
tout le monde mais vraiment d'accord sur
ces chiffres-là il ya environ deux
millions de français qui sont partis
vivre à l'étranger qui ont donc trouvé
leur bonheur ailleurs et ce nombre-là
augmente de 2 à 3 % tous les ans en
france
après on accueille aussi énormément
d'étrangers on accueille par exemple des
étudiants on est le troisième pays au
monde qui accueille le plus d'étudiants
étrangers et c'est chouette ça permet
aux cultures de se rencontrer et nous
même on envoie environ un tiers de nos
étudiants à l'étranger et un tiers qui
le même mot pas le même par aussi faire
un stage à l'étranger et c'est super ça
permet à tout le monde de se rencontrer
aujourd'hui justement grâce à internet
vous avez plus vraiment de raison de ne
pas bouger de pas voyager même en
restant devant votre ordinateur vous
avez accès à tout un tas de sites à tout
un tas d'informations
et justement le but si vous voyagez
c'est d'utiliser ces informations en
ligne d'utiliser ces sites pour créer
des communautés de gens qui sont partis
à l'autre bout du monde et qui ont eu
d'autres idées et de partager toutes ces
idées que vous avez ces communautés de
gens qui voyagent et les gens qui
voyagent ils ont peut-être une meilleure
compréhension du monde parce qu'ils
l'ont vu différemment ils sont allés
ailleurs ils ont vu d'autres systèmes
ils ont vu d'autres modes de pensée ils
ont écouté d'autres valeurs d'autres
meurent et peut-être de fait ils sont
plus tolérants ils sont plus ouverts
ils ont ouvert leur esprit à d'autres
cultures et du coup ça marche et
échanger des idées je vous dis pas que
vous allez révolutionner le monde vous
pouvez échanger des idées sur n'importe
quoi ça soit une super recettes de
cuisine que vous avez piqué en thaïlande
ou alors un super système politique
égalitaire qui marcherait super bien
mais ça on n'a toujours pas trouvé c'est
vrai et si vous arrivez à voir le monde
de manière un peu plus globale à se dire
que ben telle personne
elle peut tout simplement à l'ailé telle
personne parce que vous l'avez vu que
vous avez réussi à piquer une idée là
bas pour faire bouger les choses
positivement dans votre pays dans votre
coin
même dans votre famille peu importe
votre mentalité alors à changer et si
elle change au niveau personnel je pense
sincèrement que vous pouvez les faire
changer à des niveaux beaucoup plus
grand que pour vous même pour vous
parler aujourd'hui plus concrètement
d'exemple et ben je pense que beaucoup
d'entre vous ici sont concernés par le
voyage étudiants à partir faire ses
études à l'étranger c'est c'est un
premier pas c'est un pas assez chouette
et en plus vous pouvez avant de partir
regarder des programmes qui vont vous
permettre de mettre en avant des
compétences que vous n'avez pas
forcément mis en avant durant aux études
françaises
je pense par exemple au royaume uni où
les cours sont beaucoup plus pratique
que théorique
alors peut-être qu'en partant au royaume
uni vous serez confrontés à un monde du
travail à un monde des responsabilités
qui vous permettra d'utiliser toutes vos
compétences d'une autre manière
à l'opposé si vous êtes quelqu'un de
très studieux et bien en corée du sud en
asie peu importe les cours eux sont
beaucoup plus sérieux ça vous permettra
de vous pousser d'aller plus loin tout
en évoluant dans une autre culture et en
étant parti à l'étranger vous aurez deux
formes de plus value est extrêmement
importante la première est basse et vous
aurez peut-être appris notre langue et
la deuxième c'est qu'on voudra comme une
personne de débrouillarde
après je vous dis pas que partir en
voyage étudiants trois mois ça va
changer votre vie et ça va changer votre
vision
si ce qui a été dit est vrai et que king
jong hoon le dictateur de la corée du
nord est vraiment parti faire ses études
en suisse ni vos libertés d'expression
niveau système politique bac ça a été
comme pisser dans un violon il a
absolument rien appris après si vous
partez pour le travail donc là que vous
vous fondez dans un milieu professionnel
nouveau en apportant vos bagages de
français et aussi en rencontrant un
nouveau système
et bien tout simplement vous serez un
employé qui s'est beaucoup mieux
travailler en équipe et peut-être je
vous souhaite un meilleur manager
quand vous partez pour le travail certes
vous pouvez partir dans un endroit qui
vous fait personnellement rêver mais
hormis ça ce que vous pouvez faire est
ce que vous devriez faire c'est
peut-être vous renseigner de voir dans
quel pays on n'a besoin de personne avec
votre qualification et en partant dans
le bon pays vous aurez accès à plus de
responsabilité un meilleur poste
et peut-être pourquoi pas un meilleur
salaire il ya des gens qui en partant
justement voir le monde
on peut faire exploser leur business on
va prendre l'exemple de la famille dit
ouah la famille dit ouah c'est une
famille écossaise qui fait du whisky
depuis la moitié du 19e siècle et de
père en fils en fille ils ont tous
hérité de la boîte il y en a un il a dit
moi je me casse je vais faire le tour du
monde
j'ai voir comment on fait le whisky est
ailleurs et puis je vais revenir et mon
whisky il sera encore meilleur
et ben oui ça a marché il a eu raison il
allait piquer des idées ailleurs pour
son travail pour ses idées et ça a super
bien marché
la dernière forme de voyage qu'elle
voudrait vous parlez vite fait c'est le
voyage solidaire humanitaire donc vous
le savez tous ici ça va être partir à la
rencontre d'une nouvelle population d'un
nouveau peuple et de les aider pour
améliorer leur mode de vie
vous pouvez travailler sur un refuge et
éducationnel sur un sujet de valeur à
travers le sport par exemple où quelque
chose de plus pratique la construction
d'un système d'irrigation de bâtiments
etc voire même des thèmes très dures
comme la violence la famille
l'absence d'accès aux soins partir en
voyage solidaire ça vous sortira
complètement de votre confort ça brisera
vos idées vous serez pas juste dans une
nouvelle culture vous pourrez regarder
le monde différemment vous pourrez
regarder le fait que tous les hommes
sont égaux mais en fait ne le sont pas
et peut-être vous pourrez changer les
choses ensuite ce qui est très compliqué
de faire
si qu'il faut absolument rechercher les
associations avec lesquelles vous partez
et savoir où va l'argent savoir si
quelque chose a été fait avant savoir si
justement et ben ça marche dans le
concret parce que aider à court terme
c'est déjà bien mais si on peut aider à
long terme et pas c'est encore mieux
et une dernière funk qui se développe ça
s'appelle le toit ming toi ming ça veut
dire bravo louise michel
désolé pour l'accent donc voyager avec
une mission et ça permet à n'importe
lequel d'entre vous quand vous voyagez
ébats de pouvoir avoir accès par exemple
à une école en birmanie où ils n'ont pas
de prof de géographie et vous bas vous
avez une éducation de géographie et du
coup gratuitement en échange du logement
ou du couvert et bien vous allez pouvoir
enseigner
voilà je vais m'arrêter avant de vous
perdre en fait je veux juste que vous
reteniez une chose est cassé vous prenez
votre sac voyage et vous allez changer
sans vous en rendre compte vous allez
apprendre sans même avoir à vous y
forcer et ça va être super pour vous
[Applaudissements]